hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw tonight I
went and saw venom I really wanted to
see all horror films during the month of
October and I still did because this was
a horror because this was horribly bad I
could get it the dad joke I just made it
wasn't actually horribly bad the reviews
that I've been seeing online just tweets
by people which is not how I should get
my news now that I'm thinking about it
but have they been terrible while it is
definitely a mess in some places I
thought that it was visually really cool
there was some really cool relationship
things happening let's just get into it
venom the movie that is most definitely
canon after spider-man 3 you can quote
me on that it's not just kidding I wish
that would be amazing
these are the kind of camera just saw
episodes that I really enjoy doing
because I'm actually excited about the
content I was very excited to see venom
I really liked the character venom I
think it's a really cool thing to have
this antihero I am not pissed about what
they gave us
I wish it would have been rated R and I
wish that we would have seen like any
kind of deaths I think he kills like
five people in the whole entire movie
and he's like this crazy powerful alien
or symbiotic you know he's he's got some
of these let's get some of those you
know what I mean
there's no blood when venom rips the
head off of like his victim
there's no blood even with like gunshot
wounds and stuff like that Eddie Brock
gets hit by a truck and then breaks like
all of his bones and like there's open
wounds and there's barely inches what
pg-13 can show blood I've seen pg-13
with a lot more blood than this it was
just a that was a super weird choice it
was almost in your face how pg-13 this
movie was versus the are that it could
have been I think there's a really good
r-rated Marvel films that are fun and we
want those films I don't imagine that
this is going to be in any kind of
universe that we know of right now I
think this might be starting its own
I really don't imagine they're gonna put
him in with you know Tom Holland
spider-man that would be very weird the
world-building in this was pretty lazy
it felts very bland it felt like if I
would have seen this in 2009 I'd have
been like oh my god are you kidding me
but now after like the advances that
we've seen in superhero comic book films
it just it felt a little lazy right down
to it like the first scene is Tom Hardy
waking up next to his beautiful wife
Michelle Williams and her fiance sorry
not married never got married their
apartment for him I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to find a reference photo
to show you guys because the movie just
came out but it's very very very very
very very very very very bland I thought
maybe she was like a mistress or they
were like cheating on their spouses
because it felt like a hotel room I was
like oh they're meeting cuz they both at
wedding rings on say oh no they're just
engaged in it in their hand
what decorates like that that is a hotel
painting it's such a Tamara complaint
but when things aren't built up like
that then the relationships diminish a
bit I don't think that Tom Hardy and
Michelle Williams had incredible
chemistry but I do think small details
like that like if they had had like a
very specific world around them I think
that would have like helped in in that
and the whole world kind of felt like
that it all felt pretty just like they
could be anywhere in any setting and
it's really not specific at all critics
are really tearing this thing apart but
the audience that I was with loved it
they were laughing at things I didn't
particularly find funny I think a big
flaw of this film is that a lot of
recent Marvel films and I know this
wasn't all Marvel they were just kind of
included there because it's not all
theirs right it's with Sony um
I think though a lot of art like lead
leading men are heroes right now are
these like capable studly but also
quirky and really funny they have to
have a really funny comedic edge and
we're talking like our Chris Evans or
Chris Pratt's or
Chris Pines or Chris Hemsworth or
Chris's the quadruple Chris Tom Hardy is
a very awkward dude I like that in
certain things for me the cut of the
comedy with him landed at all and I
think there were some obvious grabs at
it and other people did so maybe this is
just me being nitpicky but it felt
pretty awkward pretty like it just was
right below the cuff of like a really
funny line the script also didn't lend
him any favors
I think the script was the biggest
failure of this movie if the script was
written better if the villain was
written better if Eddie Brock was
written better if the relationship
between him and his fiancee were written
better it none of the relationships were
written really well
none of the dialogue was written really
well none of it was written well except
for the relationship between Eddie Brock
and venom and I think a lot of that has
to do with Tom Hardy I think that that's
where he really shined is where the
movie really shine is the relationship
between them there's a scene where
there's a bunch of cars chasing Eddie
Brock and then venom and the only
interesting parts of the whole chase is
a long chase it's just not interesting
action I don't necessarily think he was
directed very well it was very dark it
wasn't exciting but when he was talking
to venom on his bike when venom was
helping him out and there was some
really good use of powers of venom that
was the only exciting part about it I
was really excited to see a lot more use
of Venom's powers I do think that they
were well showcased and I think visually
it looks really cool I was not upset
with the visuals at all there's a scene
at the end where venom is fighting riot
the ultimate villain of the movie and
you see them it's like what like in the
comics you see venom splitting from
Eddie Brock and carnage or not carnage
riots looting from the the human villain
of the story I forget his name he was
pretty boring again I think that's the
script but you know it like in the
comics where they split apart from the
human for a bit and it's like very winky
and stringy and it's awesome Irie
love the visuals of that fight photos
cool there's a lot of really really
cheesy lines though that just feel like
here we are in a 90s action comic book
film you know for smart guy you really
are a dumbass do you ever feel like your
life is one momentum screw up what and
there's a Tootsie reference god don't I
love Tootsie I don't love Tootsie
Jenny slate who plays Monalisa
Saperstein in Parks and Recreation he's
in this movie and I love her so so much
and she was so delightful in this I
didn't recognize her at first because
she was playing such a drastically
different character and her voice
sounded different and her she just was
such a transformation just a side note
no one watching this review is gonna be
very interested in that but now you know
I just scared my cat I'm sorry about the
money please
a lot of weird direction choices that
just didn't really make sense when he
first is introduced to venom he has this
running away scene where he's being
chased right he's running away scene
it's what the real critics call it
that's what the true film critics like
to call it as a running away scene ask
anyone there's a chase scene where he's
running out of this institution where
he's just been ignited with venom these
guys surrounds him and they all have
guns pointed at him and then he just
disappears and all the guys like coming
together and they're like murder Nikko
where could he possibly be and they're
surrounding a giant tree and it's like
well maybe one of you look up I don't
see why any of you wouldn't look oh
you're not gonna look straight up the
only possible direction he could have
gone now maybe just like one guy in the
back who was like oh maybe I just didn't
see him like no one's even gonna know
okay cool cool cool cool I am happy to
report the venom does kiss Tom larkey in
this movie he kisses him as Michelle
Williams character because he takes her
over for a brief spell but then it
really does seem we're very much getting
into
some spoilers here so just watch out
there but it very much does seem like
like venom falls for Tom Hardy like
venom falls in love with Eddie Brock and
I would love it
he's like alright I was gonna take over
the whole world and eat everyone's heads
off but instead I decided to save you
and save you from riots and we're gonna
do this together because I like you as a
host and he's like what really made you
stay he's like you Eddie you and then
they launch off into the night to to
take care of riots man still a better
love story than Twilight right
it just it was missing a couple really
big things and I think a script rewrite
would have done him so much good adding
instant legit good comedy or just not
attempting comedy I think the
relationships should have been built up
a lot more I think that the
world-building should have been built up
a lot more I think that there should
have been more kissing between venom
all-in-all I enjoyed it I thought it was
pretty I I didn't get bored and I'm glad
that I saw it alright thank you so much
for watching I'll see you next week
you know for a smart guy you really are
a dumb ass
[Music]